il y avait quatre nommés Anisha Tiana
Stan et Julien Stan et Julien sont
sortis on va regarder tout de suite un
extrait de leur soirée de vendredi pour
les accueille en plateau nous en dirons
plus sur leur expérience au château et
puis surtout on viendra avec Julien sur
tout ce qui s'est passé parce qu'il a
fait énormément parler c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi
je me donne envie
de la Star Academy c'est la fin de
l'aventure
pour Julien et Stanislas quel beau
parcours pour ces deux garçons
[Applaudissements]
alors je t'aime beaucoup tu sais mais
c'est vrai que voilà Julien comme je
regarde l'émission mais je regarde sur
tous les embrouilles
donc forcément c'est vrai que Julien
voilà je me suis retrouvé en lui ça va
mon juju ça va et toi nickel tu es
content d'être sorti ou pas carrément
ouais ça fait du bien un peu de
retrouver la vie normale c'est rigolo tu
es content
toi aussi ouais très content très
content de retrouver les proches la
famille c'est un moment où on en peut
plus un moment non mais c'est que ça
fait du bien aussi de redescendre et de
revenir à la vraie vie de retrouver pas
forcément le téléphone mais les
restaurants le McDo tout ça quoi
c'est le McDo qui te manquait le plus
alors
ça t'a fait du bien tu viens d'où toi
moi je suis né à Paris mais j'ai vécu
les trois quarts du temps en Bretagne
d'accord côté de Vannes Morbihan j'adore
et donc tu as retrouvé toute ta famille
en Bretagne
il fait des potes quand même ouais il y
a de très belles connaissances des
comment
le style je t'apprendrai j'adore ta
veste elle est très très lourde oui ou
merde
j'adore ah je kiffe Julien oui tu
regrette d'avoir participé ou tu étais
content ah pas du tout je regarde
absolument rien c'est génial bien sûr
c'est trop bien eh mais tu as fait
beaucoup parler toi tu as été sauvé
combien de fois depuis trois fois deux
fois deux fois qu'elle est encore
franchement je croisais les doigts bien
sûr je voulais trop mais bon après voilà
c'est le jeu
est-ce que il y a plein de gens j'ai vu
là à chaque fois il disait du piston
dans la star acade vous rien à voir pas
du tout personne vous avez fait le
casting comme ça exactement chez moi
personnellement on est venu me voir sur
les réseaux on m'a dit tu veux venir je
fais ok tout de suite
il y a une séquence dans laquelle leur
t’embrouille qui a fait polémique on
s'en rappelle un de cette séquence voilà
moi je t'avais je t'avais défendu j'ai
défend moi j'ai défendu tout le monde en
fait là j'étais la Suisse là dessus et
c'est vrai que moi je disais on a besoin
de personnalité comme toi
dans les dans les talk-shauts dans les
voilà dans les dans les dans les voilà
dans les talent chauds c'est vrai que
parce que sinon on se fait chier et
voilà toi
ou pas mais c'est vrai bah regarde
regarde en fait le truc c'est que j'ai
l'impression que vous avez vraiment du
mal à comprendre que le public mette
vraiment beaucoup et on a affaire du
public oui parce que si tu respectais le
public tu le draguerais pas en caméra
et dis pas non de la tête et regarde-moi
quand je te parle c'est humain tu as été
mal le médecin est venu tu as été mal
oui d'accord qu'est-ce qu'on en a à
faire le public t'aime qu'est-ce qu'on
en a à faire
oui sur scène c'est à toi de voir
c'est super merci
alors Julien bon c'est vrai que ça y est
c'est oublier ça bien sûr c'est bon
s’excuser après c'était adorable elle
est venue elle m'a expliqué on est
repartir sur une bonne base et puis
voilà c'était fini pour elle aussi
c'était très compliqué parce qu'elle a
eu il y a plein de gens qui lui sont
tombés dessus sur les réseaux tout ça
aussi
je sais qu'elle était elle était sale
lui a fait mal en fait tout ça mais toi
aujourd'hui voilà c'est vrai que si vous
étiez c'est que vous étiez pas compris
en fait voilà on était pas sur la même
longueur d'onde mais plus même elle a
fait elle a fait son travail de prof
quoi voilà elle était autoritaire elle
allait jusqu'au bout quoi mais voilà je
lui en veux pas c'est pas grave tu
regrette tout ce qui s'est passé autour
ou pas du tout c'est-à-dire tout là
toute la voilà j'aime pas dire polémique
mais le buzz voilà qui est où
c'est vrai que ça fait c'est un peu
embêtant quoi enfin voilà c'est ça fait
jamais du bien de recevoir du mal des
gens quoi donc mais bon voilà après moi
je trouve que ça c'est un truc à deux
balles ça va franchement c'est pas une
affaire de d'État non plus
passer à autre chose alors moi il y a un
samedi soir ta chanté avec take regarde
c'était fort pourtant je comprends pas
que tu étais éliminé regarde
[Musique]
le vent à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
alors Stan toi tu as chanté avec feu
chatterton on regarde un extrait de ta
prestation tu connais fucharton
[Rires]
[Musique]
on regarde tout de suite
merde
on en rêvait tout
[Musique]
faire dans
[Applaudissements]
Julien était stressé
tranquille lui toi tu es un peu stressé
avec tac non partout à chaque fois dans
l'aventure parce que j'ai vu
j'ai vu il y a un moment tu t'es senti
pas très bien dans les vestiaires
regarde je suis pas très stressé comme
mec de base voilà j'essaie justement de
déstresser les gens
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
on est passé c'est la nouvelle
génération nous on se serait jamais
permis de dire des choses aussi
j'adore péter Julien voilà merci pour
cette déclaration Julien le titre de
l'album
[Rires]
c'est pas la chose c'est quand c'est
avec toi Julien qui a fait énormément
parler il y a aussi lors d'un cours de
danse avec Yanis Marshall tu as pas
voulu danser en talon regarde cette
semaine c'est la semaine des impôts du
coup je vous ai offert des petits
cadeaux ouais
moi je me propose on les ouvre en même
temps tous génial tu peux le faire au
premier si tu veux
[Rires]
non non non non non
voilà non je m'en fous pas moi tu
comprends je sais pas ça
pourquoi
déjà du premier fait j'étais
complètement malade déjà pour ça et puis
j'avais pas envie de me péter une
cheville de par la suite parce que
j'avais un problème assuré tout
simplement et que voilà
un peu la flemme de me faire une
cheville avant après quoi c'est pas ça
mon chéri
[Rires]
mais je comprends je comprends pourquoi
après j'ai peut-être eu des mots forts
aussi tout ça mais en tout cas je
respecte tout ça tout à fait cet univers
j'ai totalement kiffé être l'assistant
personne aussi c'était vraiment un truc
assez drôle à faire quoi donc voilà et
là Julien vous avez l'air tout calme il
y a plus de polémique etc
à vous poser est-ce qu'on vous a pas
viré parce que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
me donne à fond parce que franchement
j'attendais qu'une chose c'était ça
court en talon et je suis trop content
je me donne au max
bon les mecs
on a rigolé on a été sympa je vais vous
poser toutes les questions vraiment que
les gens se posent sur terre Academy
est-ce que ça magouillé ce que ça peut
magouiller ce qu'on peut voilà
magouiller voilà ou parce que sinon j'y
vais pas non est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il peut y avoir magouilles sur les
votes sur les trucs
on a chié nos évaluations
et après c'est le public qui fait le
reste donc après nous et puis après elle
est aussi nos camarades qui choisissent
le deuxième rentrant dans le château et
donc
est-ce qu'il y a eu ce que ça s'est
pécho
très très sale rien
même pas une petite
là pourquoi
on est venu là
et alors oui pas moi
et t'as pas pu faire un détournement et
un gardien mec non c'est vrai bah oui
non pas de téléphone Julien est-ce que
est-ce que si c'était possible est-ce
que est-ce que Nola répète ton style
[Rires]
oui c'est une très belle femme mais
est-ce que tu as eu un petit crush sur
quelqu'un franchement
[Applaudissements]
génération
mais moi je suis en couple je suis
arrivé en couple madame
je vais te dire
on a une voiture
on a déjà on est déjà habillé qu'on
garde pas les vitrines
sont des très jolies filles maintenant
je suis en couple je suis très bien et
je suis quelqu'un de fidèle donc merci
pour l'artiste il y avait des caméras
partout frère
de la Star Ac et on a des pauses on a
déjà
tu veux pas bouger c'est
bon donc les gars il y avait rien à
faire
maintenant est-ce que tu sens que ça
bouge pour toi sentimentalement depuis
que tu es sorti de la star
mais arrête de mentir Julien je te sors
je te sens Julien arrête là c'est un
petit mytho je vais pas te mentir c'est
un petit mytho bien sûr mais c'est vrai
que ça bouge un peu plus mais voilà
enfin c'est à dire que ça bouge
il y a des bails pour l'instant il y a
pas de bail là pour l'instant je vais
pas te mentir il y a aucun bail choisi
Lolo tu cherches du sexe on lui en
propose je te dis non moi j'ai rien dit
moi je veux savoir si il a baisé
j'embrasse très fort Jennifer c'est son
anniversaire aujourd'hui c'est un gros
bisou à Jennifer son anniversaire
je l'aime j'adore Jennifer qu'est-ce
qu'il y a des gentil bon les chéris vous
regrettez rien alors vous allez faire
quoi maintenant de votre truc toi j'ai
compris jockey
que la veste en plus je l'adore elle est
très très lourde qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire attends vous allez continuer
dans la musique maintenant je pense
qu'il faut faire du tremplin pour
persister dans la musique moi
personnellement j'aimerais aussi aller
dans le milieu du cinéma et je vous dis
les deux vous avez vous avez un vrai
truc franchement
tu veux faire du cinéma mais aussi ouais
moi je veux mon rêve c'est de venir
chanteur performeur donc danser chanter
en même temps tu vas continuer là-dedans
tu fais quoi dans la vie avant bah
écoutez j'ai je me suis occupé de mon
grand-père pendant Raoul pas mal
d'années voilà à très bientôt
tu as arrêté les cours ouais j'ai arrêté
les cours à 17 ans je suis monté sur
Paris pour essayer de faire de rentrer
dans l'univers artistique tu vas réussir
je le sens merci tu vas voir j'ai le pif
pour ça j'avais dit
un petit peu on va continuer la musique
le plus possible
tu m'arrêtes et j'ai une connerie en
premier lieu ce que je fais c'est que je
vais rentrer chez moi je vais voir ma
famille un petit peu parce que ça fait
longtemps que je les ai pas vu en fait
un amour ancien tu l'embrasses de ma
part ça fait grand plaisir gros bisous
et sinon après et sinon à part ça ouais
après je consacré sur la musique la
compo
la prod enfin tout ça faire un petit peu
proposer des maquettes quoi on propose
propose propose que tu veux mais en tout
cas on sera là si tu as besoin un jour
de faire un live toi aussi insta c'est
un honneur merci d'avoir les chéris
franchement merci d'avoir été là et
merci et continuez kiffer les choses
[Applaudissements]